Ah, I'm grateful that this will go to Kumo or have it prepared for me.It
's the first time I've actually cooked it, and so on.It's the breeder who says, "It depends on
Yoshino Gozan and the time of year, but
bear meat has a pretty bad smell."
Compared to deer and wild boar, it's meat that needs a little more attention.
It's a nice scent. It's certainly a little wild, but it's totally good. I took a
quick bite.
Beast-like
a It
certainly has a special
smell Even if you're a reporter on the train,
Well, this time it was just simply grilled.
As soon as you enter, you'll understand that
this special meat needs a little bit of odor removal.
Well, my opponent doesn't like to compete in the ring, but
anyway, next time, I'll use the ingredients in my room right now,
and be conscious of removing
odors.
They are the authorities of molecular gastronomy, and if they are concerned about rebels, they will not hesitate to provide any kind of support. That's what Yasuzumi Azumi says.
I don't care if you
take me home My bear meat dish is already assembled here Can you
say that I've perfected the perfect spice in a few minutes even if it's fragile
[music]